[Musica]
oggi nuova challenge dovremo comprare e
mangiare solo cose del colore dei nostri
me sinceramente lo vedevo l'ora di
montare e smontare cosa e invece io
potremmo andare solo cose rose bianche e
nere ma anche di blu che cosa quindi
anche colta ma io sono sicuro che
riuscirò a trovare qualcosa da mangiare
che blu chissà perché ma me lo sento
per trovare cose da valutare anche se
muscolare un po strano ma io mi metto
anche cappellino rosa così potrò
comprare e mangiare anche 0 0 giusto non
è giusto che voglio cappelline euro del
prezzo video raggiunge i 25 mila mi
piace 14 maggio anche le cose della vita
faremo un'altra parte in cui non vi
spoiler o ancora come sceglieremo i
colori ma partiva bene quindi lasciate
un mi piace qui sotto e iniziamo subito
loro brucia l'anima e che ci passiamo in
macchina siamo diretti verso uno dei
nostri ristoranti preferiti in assoluto
a roma si chiama romio capistro non solo
è buonissimo ma la cosa più bella di
questo ristorante che ci sono i gatti
dentro devi sapere nei commenti se
conoscete questo ristorante se sì siete
mai stati
ora comunque cerchiamo di farvelo vedere
un pochino e speriamo di trovare
qualcosa di rosso per me o rosso o
bianco
corrotta poi ho anche la condannerà e
scarpe nere e lo spazio rosa invece
d'italia cene feste blu tu hai poche
sente voglio vedere vitale come se la
caverà fronti
[Musica]
una cosa
sì
[Musica]
rosa come di all indietro
questi sono i trucks blu per di tali
anche se ci sono cose di altri colori
tano gullo
contenta si sono colte il testo
destino
[Musica]
che possiamo promettere il mito rosso
sono sempre molto rosso ma noi no
non mangio io volevo
[Musica]
guardate che bella questa corsa è il
colore bianco e rosso
[Musica]
ovviamente evitare che la vuole mangiare
tutti allora è giusto si massaggiava no
no
[Musica]
è buona come la saggia non penso come no
e questi qua di nuovo in macchina e
abbiamo finito di mangiare centro
commerciale in cui dovremo comprare
[Musica]
queste sono le indicazioni delle
sapienze comunque non sarebbe comprare
solo cosa dei nostri colori
ci riusciremo permettono a molto
difficile anche perché adora comprare
cose roland hanna decidiamo una
penitenti da chi compra le cose non del
colore mangia i vestiti non potrà
mangiare per un'ora per ogni quota del
colore diverso comprata e capitano ora
commissario a mangiare una nuova era
quindi vuol dire già più di mangiare
qualcosa non detto sarà quindi sento
mangio compri cinque volte di colori
diversi per cinque ore non potrei
mangiare
purtroppo per berlino sarà felicissimo e
quali no tutte le distrugge in 5 secondi
per cena burger trotta è un po viola
burger verde e ma non è più quello che
hai fatto con il verde e 37 1 il buono
certo c'è del verde nel blues e blu
verde non puoi mangiare per un'ora ha
detto questi burger colorati e si
chiamano flowers burger
burger vegetariani e buonissimi e
guardate
è tutto
no
perde
vero
la parola
pfeiffer
vediamo come si sa bene
sarà bello perdere così adesso per buono
eccoci qua siamo tornati evitare ha già
varato con il panino verde potevo
cambiati perché in realtà questo è il
giorno dopo crati capelli un po bagnati
comunque è la challenge è ancora attiva
monitoraggio ha barato perché è mangiato
il barino verde invece di mangiare il
panino blu ma non c'era non c'era
blocchi ma vediamo le cose che abbiamo
comprato vediamo quante ore chi dovrà
stare questo mangiare allora iniziamo
con le mie cose ma è vitale per a vedere
le sue che giochino allora io li colori
rosso bianco rotta in nero quindi questo
il rosso e nero un giochino per melina
mi piace se volete vedere la reazione di
berlino quando prenderà questo giochino
anzi seguitemi su instagram in merito
storico nel lettore si faccia vedere
sempre merlino perché voi vedete sempre
voglio vedere per lì io voglio vedere
merlino e quindi andate a seguirmi in
punto già per me perché il rosso bianco
ai questa maglietta di snejder di rose
bianca poi ho scoperto che in realtà
questo magnete da uomo ma vabbè catene
freni
un altro punto per me poi questa
maglietta che un rosso più il colore
delle mie unghie rosa mi sembra così
fosse come nei miei occhi quindi un
altro punto per bear punti veramente poi
questo cerchietto che in realtà ha un po
di colori però anche volta quindi sta
qui le compatte solo perché vi piace non
è un punto
va bene bene quindi poi alla fine
scrivete nei commenti qual è la cosa che
mi è piaciuta più distrugge tra queste
cose che abbiamo comprato io ho preso
questo speaker per sentire la musica e
de rosa quindi da un altro punto per me
fra cui diversi per chiudere le buste di
patatine e di confezioni ed evo sempre
mettervi perché evitare le ombre
tantissime di confezioni basa di e di
cibo quindi questo note le bollette
perché dovrei rota quindi poiché 44
punti vediamo se è vitale mi batte
allora io avevo i colori nero grigio
grigio del jeans diciamo e blu e il nero
di che cosa per le scarpe che allora mo
grigio jeans grigio sarete va bene dai
ok un punto tiri più di tutti per quella
che è
poi abbiamo un'altra capita è tenero
uguale bastava mettere il colore è
questo questa gente come un pecorino
meno 1 un fantasma contenuto adesso meno
leone anche se sarei qui
il punto è che siamo per poi aspetta poi
abbiamo il blu
vabbè c'è un po di roma mi aspetta la
maggior parte di questa maglietta blu ma
perché io ho tolto un punto per il
cerchietto da questo prodotto questo
effetto portato mezzo punto ma poi
abbiamo rosso perché mi stava benissimo
no ma io non ci avevo il russamento
volare rossonere mia quindi meno 11 ora
no so 0 punti e poi abbiamo abbiamo
questi calzini che sono perfetti guarda
li ho scelti proprio apposta blu e nero
l'invito è un punto a punto un punto e
supporti buddista via tre inumani bianco
sta bene con tutto quindi destituzione
di bianco 0 come no fa parte del pri
vige il bianco lanna reti a 0 a 0 ma
quando progetto troppo parte cosmetica
più di me e io di calzi stimare idrici
tutti i grigi quindi sto zero punti noi
già detto no a uno era un po vicina al
mio fan a taiz tu stai a me non voglio
disegnare sulle scalette rosa e giallo
quindi nessuno dei tuoi colori tranne
rosa
e punti marchionne o due punti sei tu no
non è vero mentre tre quindi chi vince
questa salesi io vado per la legge
fiscale dovrà stare un'ora senza
mangiare che impossibile perché tutta le
mangia sempre in continuazione ha già
svuotato il frigo qua il cioccolato di
pantaloni piazza primo maggio prima
rispettare le regole della challange no
smi amico e blu al rosso
lasciate un mi piace per vedere un altro
di queste challenge e per far maggiore
avital a 25 mila mi piace ci sarà
un'altra di verseggiare in serata super
divertente anzi scegliete voi la
penitenza della prostituzione nei
commenti qual è stato il vostro oggetto
preferito per me il cerchietto con i
fiori e per te per te la maglietta la
maglietta verde perché lui si trova
niente morirono barzelletta di cheese il
panino verde quello è stato un bel mi
piace vi lasciamo con quattro case lines
pubblicare per vedere i nostri altri
video a caso quello che preferite buona
mezzo